tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono pari j
oggi andiamo avanti con autostrada 0
rimasti che eravamo qui alle docce
praticamente successo che nell'ultimo
episodio è finito che mi hanno
accoltellato la dietro c'erano due tizi
nudi che mi hanno praticamente a
coltellate io sono andato avanti l'ho
già aperta la porta che cazzo vuoi sono
andato avanti praticamente qui i ragazzi
prima di andare avanti voglio fare una
cosa che mi avete detto in 50mila allora
dovrebbe essere qui st donati un mostra
sottotitoli siete contenti adesso non
perché me l'avete fatto notare tipo
tutti quindi dovevo assolutamente farlo
ragazzi adesso ci sono i sottotitoli
così capite qualcosa di si vogliono
andare in impostazioni
così capita qualcosa di quello che
dicono anche se sinceramente non voglio
saperlo vabbè comunque nuovo rimasti
laga che c'erano due tizi nudi
ovviamente che esci passando per le
docce usciamo dal suo posto di merda
john keats i nudi e uno mi aveva
infilzato da dietro visto e considerato
che erano lunghi non voglio pensare con
cosa mi ha infilzato c'è c'è ecco
perfetto ragazze c'è un t allora amico
mio mi fa piacere che c'è il birillo ma
nessuno ti autorizzo ad infilzarli con
quello perfetto ragazzi è una gang bang
io devo riuscire
[Musica]
alla fine si scopre che ce lo più grosso
io un fatemelo entrambi mio zio come un
pazzo non lo so
ravviso del sarcasmo raga io prima non
ci avevo i sottotitoli quindi non è
normale che questi due parlino cioè
questi chi vuol dire che dicono
effettivamente cose sensate dove sono
non li vedo più
bentornati sono spariti racca benissimo
allora erano laggiù
devo aver li ha girati in qualche modo
noi andiamo avanti perché io già non
vedo più nulla bene abbiamo superato
quel punto quindi già ci siamo vediamo
già questa porta ok famiglie bene
ragazzi ci vedo grazie a dio
cos'è questa una porta aperta mio di non
ci posso credere una porta aperta in sto
gioco è un miracolo
possiamo non so devo allora devo fuggire
dalle docce sinceramente prima che ero
appeso alla finestra ero già fuori
cos'è una sottospecie di di certo 3.0
diciamo che dato che la gente su auto
aspettava di scaricarsi nel cesso ne
hanno verso uno senza lo scarico vabbè
come al solito mi faccio qualche domanda
andiamo avanti perché sennò non avanzo
mai dove stiamo le son finiti entro
nella security serve mica una tessera
buongiorno a lei senza un attimo c'è un
suo collega nella stanza di prima tutti
col caffè che cazzo senso il caffè che
ammazza tutti quanti non lo so premi
pulsanti signori
[Applauso]
ora tu ci hai dato dentro ma veramente
troppo al mcdonald cazzo ragazzi c'è un
tizio mezzo c'è un tizio peso che ha
sfondato il muro o mio dio mio dio abbia
portato li ha portati non si apre non si
apre non si apre buongiorno non ho gli
hamburger cazzo non si lenin qui ha
inizio non si apre sentiti allora
facciamo così io lotto su facebook ti
tengo conto sin figo ragazzi ci hanno
mottola si aperta la porta è aperta la
botola si no sì sì mia scollacciato non
lasciarmi più brutto stronzo tipo mito
in faccia ragazza abbiamo fatto non so
neanche come però lo sento ancora cioè
non è non è completamente finita la cosa
mi sa io non scenderei però mi sento
costretto sì poiché altro io lo sapevo
ok ok lo aprì la porta la prima parte
proprio volto
mi ha detto dove cazzo è ok questo
abbastanza grosso non so se riesco
sono vivo sono ancora sono creativo cioè
non ci posso credere
sono ancora vivo come cazzo fatto c'è ma
neanche spider man regge a una caduta
del genere ve lo giuro che pensavo di
essere morto cioè pensavo di dover
iniziare la check point invece no che
cazzo è successo a nonno chuck non lo so
noi andiamo avanti perché non siamo più
fermi mi sa che colpì soci in groppa di
nuovo mi sa che ci ingloba lo stesso
anche se mi muovo allora non lo so forse
non mi vede al buio perché non c'è agli
infrarossi io sono tecnologico lui e
techno hamburger rega ma questo non era
il posto dove se un partito quello che
con tutte le celle e soddimo d'oro prima
cazzo sta scendendo ok ok ok ok ok calmi
calmi non bacio si sta avvicinando
ok ok don't be afraid of di obesi cioè
facciamo così allora io metto un mac
tosta terra
mi trova punto non mi trovo nicola
cristo santo lavati pantaloni mio dio ci
sarà una lavatrice sto posto non lo so
sì va bene ragazzino io non voglio avere
a che fare questa gente dove cazzo
sapevo
mio dio quanto sono stupido allora
secondo forse già passo già posso fare
già posto pare corri corri ovviamente
detto dio mio santo mi avete detto che
non devo girarmi quando corro io cosa
appena fatto una cioè però io raga non
posso tenere tanto gli infrarossi perché
sono le batterie mi vanno a minchia
quindi devo riuscire a farcela scavalca
una porta malizia non ce la fa lui non
ce la fai tu ci siamo siamo dov'era dove
la mamma d'inizio ragazze ognuno qui c'è
il mio dio ma non ci posso credere mi
dovrei far tutto che voi tutti i vizi di
prima sono tutti morti nei fatti fuori
con te li sei mangiati di la verità mi è
sparito ho perso di nuovo l'opera gallo
perdo non so perché già facciamo ci
affacciamo da che parte non lo so apri a
porta non ne a pensare all'altra
perfetto
sì sì sì che non ci passa si che non ci
passa non ci posso
non so dove sia finito sinceramente ma
ci ha rinunciato a seguirmi perché
sapeva che avrebbe perso quindi per
evitare l'umiliazione ha smesso prima
dove siamo qua non lo so dov'è cos'è
stoppa animo quello che era gallo rai e
da qualche parte ancora lì lasciamolo lì
non importa a dopo l'acquisto a stile e
facciamo lo stato ma porca [ __ ]
questo è successo che cazzo nero non so
cosa è successo ma rumore mi ha fatto
saltare in aria
cioè vabbè allora senti ti prude sembra
proprio di sì è grattate loc
vabbè a non puoi grattacielo perché c'è
la camicia di forza io non te lo grasso
amico un inutile che mi segue in un telo
grado senti e voglio aiutarti no
veramente vuoi aiutano a me forse io
devo salire qua se mi fossi insieme cioè
vabbè comunque io no io penso che cazzo
ci fai qui ciao ragazzi degli il ritorno
di spencer ma i giochi pirata glielo
ragazzi nessuno riuscirà mai a grattare
glielo ha sto povero cristo qui sotto
ma quanto riprese ragazzi guardate che
cazzo dice purtroppo è sfortunato che
gli è morto quando è caduto quindi
niente
i morti fanno esperimenti sui vivi e
vuoi sapere quali ti do un indizio è
ancora in forse l'esperimento è ancora
in corso puoi saltare alla sporgenza
monica avanti primi spazio ok vai cos'è
mio dio
ezio please non lo so che alla fine se
essere grattato meno ma io voglio uscire
di qua come faccio a pietro la porta ma
rimette ragazzi devo trovare una leva un
qualcosa è stronzo ti sento che è chi è
6 se della confraternita scura ammettilo
e non te lo gatto
insomma ragazzi c'è gente che chi tenta
di farselo grattare ovunque ragazzi
basta che usciamo di qua perché non ne
posso più vi giuro che succede qualche
[ __ ] pollami brutto stronzo fatti suoi
maledetto stronzo mi ha quasi ucciso
porca [ __ ] 3 sony sono finiti in una
cella cosa devo fare scaricarmi e forse
c'è qualcosa sotto il letto non annoierà
che non so a cosa
buongiorno senti è amico mio io sto
cercando soltanto di uscire di qua non
voglio disturbare ti stai fermo lì a
terra ok
scusami se hai avuto più paura tuo che
io va bene possiamo metterci d'accordo
no perché siamo spariti tutti e due no
ma quasi quasi così ti lascio qui senti
hai bisogno fammi uno squillo tanto sai
il mio numero
il ragazzo è finito il tizio di sotto
non lo so spero di non incontrare nessun
tizio voglioso di hamburger direi di
andare da questo che sembra molto più
tranquilla wallrider ok mi fa piacere
posso sapere chi cazzo scritto se cos'è
sul muro prima che lo me lo ritrovi
davanti più che altro poi va bene non mi
interessa sinceramente c'è qualcos'altro
devo scena ok perfetto ci siamo qui
sotto ragazzi vado a ficcare allora se
c'è un manicomio pieno di pazzi
scalmanati e dispenser sulle sedie a
rotelle che ti saltano addosso posto
peggiore di questo è soltanto le
fondamenta di quel manicomio sono sicuro
quindi raga io non vorrei entrare i sì
perché sono entrato qui dentro ma che
non so neanch'io cosa voglio trovarci
qui sotto di preciso che è successo
sventato gioco nuovo obiettivo raggiungi
le fogne
comunque se devo essere sincero sono più
tranquillo nelle foglie che li sopra
perché almeno qua non ci trovo nessuno
come non detto maledizione lo sapevo non
so se sei vivo ma non voglio scoprirlo
dormi tranquillo è mio zio mi do
affidare sempre nel bouquet più piccola
fine mi deve infilare nelle tane dei top
in poche parole
vedo la luce raga vedo la luce non so se
sono morto cosa no non sono morte una
lampadina pro vorrei trovare la fine
visto posto perché magari ecco ci sono
le braccia ve lo spiego io il perchè
l'applicazione è molto semplice per la
mente la gente che si scarica nei gesti
del manicomio come avete visto negli
episodi precedenti quelli che non
rimangono incastrati nel cesso vanno a
finire nelle fogne in poche parole raga
questa è la spiegazione più logica che
mi viene in mente
vabbè passiamo iniqua raga stiamo
andando sempre più mi sembra di giocare
a skype a bethel due valvole per far
scorrere l'acqua che i ragazzi devo far
scorrere l'acqua
credo per poi buttarmi qui sotto perché
non c'ho voglia di tuffarmi nel fisso in
poche parole questa dovrebbe essere la
soluzione a queste acquista la mappa
delle valvole allora devo raggiungere il
posto e ci sono allora io sono qui credo
anzi questi sono i tubi colorati ok
perfetto l'areo seguire i tubi colorati
ragazza e devo andare
mio dio ma il tomtom non potevi
prendertela no vabbè facciamo così con
la mappa vecchi tempi vabbè levo girare
alla seconda e poi vabbè torni indietro
pazienza un importante non mi sembra
così difficile
seguiamo il tubo giallo che è successo
obesi delle fogne maledizione io come
cazzo fa o che mi segue chi segue merda
merda ragazzi non dovevo o non dovevo
andare avanti così tranquillamente lo
sapevo che quello tornava prima o poi
come hai fatto a scaricarti nel cesso
spiega meroi
si no cazzo mi sono salvato il mio tiro
un centimetro mi ha salvato il culo
non ci posso credere va bene ok gli
spazi perché sei troppo pieno di
hamburger praga ce l'ho fatta non ci
credo devo andare allora cambio di
programma è andato dove volevo andare io
quindi seguiamo quello arancione
la prima a destra prima destra andiamo
veloci prima che passi come faccia
entrare qui dentro dove la prima a
destra con questa che gli otto ragazzi
che idiota
devo seguire c'è anche il tubo da
seguire quindi non mi sembra essere così
difficile ma io non ci arriva abbiate
pietà
dov'è la valvola male iniziare a false
quadro seguire ancora tubo si è qua
credo si ragazzi l'ho trovata la prima
la prima c'è ma anche ancora un'altra
però purtroppo l'altra è un po un casino
da seguire perché c'è quei tizi in mezzo
alle fogne e ovviamente quindi non posso
arrivarci tranquillamente come speravo e
qualcosa mi dice che mi ha già trovato
ma edizione allora ho già capito chi la
porta chi la porta
raga non solo è finito ma mi sa che mi
ha dimenticato cazzo non mi ha
dimenticata negli armadietti veloce però
c'è ragazzi non mi ha ancora visto non
ci posso credere
ok la possiamo fare vai via vai via vai
via
no no no no non è il mio non nel mio non
è mio
senti io non sono qui per ancora
scappare forza il piano scappare sono
creativo sì non ci credo telefono mi
stavo perdendo
sono ancora vivo non so come ho fatto
sopravvivere noi abbiamo corner
ragazzino rivela un'altra valvola
velocissimo non mi ricordo la strada
cycle tubo giallo perché non la sony gli
ufficiali nel tubo nel turbolento umore
tubo del tubo veloce veloce si ragazzi
non ho idea di come abbia fatto a
sfuggirgli in quel modo ce l'ha fatta
ragazzi ci siamo stanza delle valvole
maledizione ci ho messo un secolo ma ci
siamo arrivati fai così la seconda
l'arma è a posto devo tornare brevemente
dove c'era prima e usa la scala per
accedere al raccordo inferiore usa la
scala scala ma intendeva la scala di
prima ovviamente sia allora sì l'unica
cosa che non ho capito notizie di prima
perché non lo vedo più più dio qui sotto
veloce veloce no cazzo è appreso mi ha
prestato pavimento piede ma non non mi
ha fatto nulla perché ce l'abbiamo fatta
ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatto e credo
devo soltanto buttarmi nella scala di
prima e scende il canto tizio non ci
passa
ci dovremmo riuscire a strappare un
attimo ce la posso fare se non c'è più
il pisa fortunatamente ce l'abbiamo
fatta dopo secoli di corse e fughe da
tizi che vanno spesso al mcdonald ce
l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi devo soggetto
capire dove stiamo andando perché io sto
andando sempre più in giù
cioè io non penso di uscire da un
manicomio andando nel nel centro della
terra però vabbè vogliano soltanto
capire come cazzo si è finita sta gente
qui sotto c'è c'è gente nelle fogne ma
sinceramente io se non per lo scarico
dei cessi e gollum lui ragazzi c'è
gollum nelle fogne
qualcosa mi dice che dovrei starmene di
sotto più che salire qui sopra perché
c'è tizi ci sono tipi poco
raccomandabili
ma io ci salgo lo stesso perché c'è un
brutto giorno dove dove dove è partito
liquido andato cazzo sei tu dimmi che
sei tu che sbirciato brutto stronzo
cerca un altro cita dalle fogne che
cazzo di rumori brutti ci sono nelle
fogne i ragazzi non so veramente vi
giuro ci sono dei rumori raccapriccianti
in un modo assurdo
cos'è questo c'è una stanza strada
sembra la camera dei segreti racca
probabilmente ci troviamo a reporter che
scappa da basilisco
[Musica]
solo sono fa vj fermo semi una persona
che ragiona fermo parla qui conosco
anch'io da canzoni maledizione beckmann
piace ma gioca aut aut l'ass
questo gioco è pieno di pazzi che ci
hanno rotto e ica chi cazzo sei tu non
aver paura di me io e te siamo uguali
sappiamo ancora cosa reale cosa noi
questo lo vedi creare amico il dottore è
morto lo sai vero
il dottore wernick e molto prima di
iniziare a lavorare qui avrà
sinceramente non me ne frega un cazzo
però ammetto mio lavati d'affari che
razza gli esperimenti può fare un
dottore mostro su dei pazienti vivi te
lo sei chiesto tu non hai visto nulla il
confronto maledetto sto non sono mai
visto niente
me ne vado di qua perché penso che
uscirò più marco di terra suo posto di
merda comunque ragazzo mio un consiglio
utilizza latte detergente la mattina per
lavarsi la faccia perché fa miracoli
io scenderei di qua ragazzi perché sennò
non devo incontrare il tizio di prima
con la torcia perché mi sembra questa
non è acqua perfetto ragazzi penso a
perfetto c'è il bagno delle ragazze
qualcuno ha nel suo periodo vero ma mi
sa che la strada giusta è quello dei
maschi però mi sembrate più di uno stop
chi cazzo sei tu ragazzi in un pezzo di
volte ho detto che per scappare dal suo
posto non potete scaricarvi dai cessi
non serve a niente ma c'è mica un altro
bacio no perché tanto non le palle piene
visti ciccioni che corrono chi cazzo sei
tu il ragazzo di prima che tentava di
grattare solo che non ci riusciva ci sei
riuscito
ti sto seguendo per darti una mano e
voglio essere gentile tu sì sì gentile
con me facciamo sono partite le valvole
ragazzi era c'era un tizio raga qui c'è
gente che corre ma non si capisce dove
va a finire
c'è del sangue bello la madonna ma
quanto è figo questo va bè ragazzi non è
cos'è che è successo che si è fatto
un banchetto per le mosche questa fogna
non potrebbe bruciare vivi così
centinaia di cadaveri ammassati in una
stanza migliaia di mosche
e questa è la via d'uscita di cui
parlava al prete a intendi zio fester
lama zio fester e stupido sei tranquillo
comunque ai ragazzi zio fester che avete
visto negli episodi scorsi dato che non
avevo i sottotitoli scusatemi che gli ho
attivato in ritardo
praticamente mi diceva di di uscire
dalle fogne in poche parole però non
raggiungi piano terra della maschile ma
quale piano terra che siamo scesi di
sotto che cazzo mi sembra di esser
uscito in cina porca [ __ ] ai ragazzi da
qualche parte dovremo pure andare per
forza perché se no non so che cazzo fare
cos'è c'è una via episodio che gambe
sexy ragazzi togliti che devo godere di
questa scena muoviti avanti per spingere
non sapevo scusate sono alle prime armi
questo gioco ancora buongiorno se si
guarda 66 miss gambe 2013 amico mio
va bene senti non sei riuscita grattar
telo alla fine in poche parole non ti di
sperare così si però bravi accendete la
luce che non voglio rimanere da solo
questo tizio comunque sia per sicurezza
di chiudo la porta non vorrei mai che
divenissero istinti omicidi
andiamo avanti raga non so come cazzo
uscire di qua dal aspettate marchionne
c'è un'altra porta c'è una sedia mezza
scassata bene così non so devo andare
raga non ho idea
ci siamo siamo sempre ci stiamo
addentrando sempre di più i sto
maledettissimo posto ci sono scalo
ovunque
qualcosa mi dice che quella porta non è
normale però ci vado lo stesso
buongiorno sono di passaggio è che c'è
un tizio oddio gli propongo un patto
allora facciamo così io apro la porta e
to fail bubusettete
appena avrà eccepito che è che tentava
di sfondare primo ok
così almeno siamo tutti amici chi c'è
qualcuno tenta di uccidere fa vj
famiglia pacifico va beh io dico tanto
non ci posso andare anche un'altra parte
da qualche parte comunque dovrà uscire
per forza dovrebbero essere le cantine
credo qualcosa del genere siamo mi
sembra amica mi sembrano le tende di the
grudge 2 o mio dio
che schifo è cos'è cos'è c'era qualcuno
che ha parlato lusso libero che cosa
veste ragazzi cos'è non lo so chi ci ha
parlato prima
c'è qualcuno che ha parlato ma non so
dove non posso dormire seguenti che vi
aspetta nel sonno
il tizio di cui parlano tutti deve
essere il chirurgo che ha mandato tutti
quanti ha fatto impazzire tutti ragazzi
io non ho capito lista ma chi è questo
come finito lì dentro ragazzi a sfonda
stavo avaya testate tv però il mio amico
mio
però non ho capito che schifo è o mio
ragazzi ma l'enigmista non è nulla in
confronto a sta roba
va bene sto arrivando amico mio tieni
duro ciò posso fare fa vj sta arrivando
a soccorre arti ma ve ragazzi in qualche
modo lo devono aggiungere però non ho
capito ancora bene come così mi sa
perfetto qualcuno l'ultimo che ha
provato a scendere di qua non è finito
molto bene
amico mio stai calmo non impazzì questo
mi vomita ragazzi va bè ragazzi concludo
qui l'episodio perché amo tenere la
suspense congressi il video si conclude
qui noi ci vediamo in un prossimo
episodio 6 video è piaciuto come al
solito lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non
invidio trovate la descrizione cells
iscritti iscrivetevi io ci rivediamo un
prossimo video bella ragazzi